-Guys, you ever see a photo
in the news
and think the headline
should be different?
Well, we'll take care of that
right now.
It's time for
"News and Improved."
Here we go.
-♪ "News and Improved" ♪
-For example, check out
this first photo here.
The original headline was...
The headline
can definitely be improved,
because if you only
looked at the photo,
the headline could have been...
[ Laughter and applause ]
Up next, this headline says...
The headline could have been...
[ Laughter and applause ]
"How you doin'?"
"Couple scratch-offs, too."
This next headline was...
But the headline
could have been...
[ Laughter and applause ]
This next headline was...
But the headline
could have been...
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Wow.
-This next headline was...
Headline could have been...
[ Laughter and applause ]
"That was very interesting.
What you said was very,
very interesting."
[ Laughter ]
-[ Gulps ]
-This next headline was...
The headline could have been...
[ Laughter and applause ]
What? It becomes --
-Wow!
-I didn't see that coming.
-What happened?
I didn't see that.
-I didn't see it coming.
-Guess there are more tapes.
-This next headline was...
Headline could have been...
[ Laughter and applause ]
"Wow!"
And finally,
the last headline is...
Headline could have been...
That's all the time we have
for "News and Improved."